[Music]
so many people have asked and blockchain
technology helped provide answers to
challenges that typically have suffered
from lack of technology that have
suffered from poor technology
applications one of those being the way
that voting works in the United States
there's a and I I think of this in three
distinct phases right there's the phase
before voting we're keeping track of who
is registered to vote and where they're
allowed to vote has seems it's been
harder than it should have been right we
have a lot of examples of people showing
up at polling places and being denied
the right to vote and it seems like
paperwork goes missing and people get
removed from voting rolls that sort of
thing
a public ledger that tracked who is
registered to vote where and allowed
people to look at that from their home
machine and then confirm that when they
showed up at the poll would do a lot to
reestablish trust in the process of
registering to vote and validating that
everybody who is entitled to vote is
able to do that right providing an
independent verification of that the
third there's a second phase I'll get to
in a bit but there's a third phase which
is after the vote when you're taking the
totals that come from a polling place
that come from
you know vote by mail for example in
Oregon we have to kind of trust that the
system works right we have to hope that
everything's counted correctly at the
local level and then it's totaled up
correctly at the state level and then
reported nationally etc and we're
fortunately at a point where that that
the the rebase is of that trust hasn't
been violated yet but in many countries
it is in many countries there's not a
lot of confidence that the total from a
polling place is actually I actually
some doubt right so using a distributed
ledger not to track the individual votes
but to track the totals from each of the
polling places would be a way to allow
the public to understand okay the local
polling place I went and voted at is
reporting a thousand votes 500 for
candidate X 500 for candidate Y that
seems about right I don't know if my
vote specifically counted but I know
that at least the polling place that was
that counted appropriately and they
didn't try to be pretend they were a
hundred thousand votes right so at the
beginning of that process and the tail
end of that process using a public
distributed ledger to record that makes
a lot of sense
but in the middle the actual act of
walking into a booth and cat registering
a vote or a lot of people want to do
voting by mobile device or by by
computer I'm very worried about that the
digitization of that our computers fail
us all the time and malware and other
other threats could really step in and
make it so that I think I'm voting for
one candidate but ever it gets recorded
for another right and we have to think
in the United States we care quite a bit
about the confidentiality of our vote
even to the point where I get no receipt
right I can't go to a bar and prove that
I voted for somebody and get a discount
for it right that would be considered
bribery so we can't simply come up with
a system that puts all the original
votes into a public ledger and provides
proof that somebody voted away a certain
way or that becomes a corruptive process
so I think we still need voter verified
paper ballots as a path to auditing but
with the the registration the beginning
and the summing at the end conducted by
a public ledger I think we would do a
tremendous amount to re-establish
confidence in the voting system
[Music]
you